ونحييكم من جديد الاتفاق السعودي الايراني
برعايه الصين لقي ترحيبا عربيا في العراق
وسوريا ولبنان الحكومه العراقيه اعلنت عن
سعادتها لتحقيق هذا الاتفاق حيث تلقى رئيس
الوزراء العراقي محمد شيع السوداني اتصالا
هاتفيا من امين المجلس الاعلى للامن
القومي الايراني علي شمخاني عبر من خلاله
عن شكره للعراق لدوره في المفاوضات بين
السعوديه وايران والجهود العراقيه التي
بذلت من اجل تقريب وجهات النظر بين
البلدين التي اسهمت في التوصل الى الاتفاق
كما اعلنت الخارجيه العراقيه عن الاتفاق
السعودي الايراني وقالت انه سيخلق مناخا
جديدا للتفكير بمصالح المنطقه وقالت في
بيان ان هذا الاتفاق ياتي تتويجا لرؤيه
الجانبين باولويه الحوار بوصفه سبيلا لخفض
التوتر هذا هو رحبت الخارجيه السوريه
بالاتفاق قائله ان هذه الخطوه المهمه
ستقود الى تعزيز الامن والاستقرار في
المنطقه والى التعاون الذي سينعكس ايجابا
على المصالح المشتركه لشعبي البلدين خاصه
ولشعوب المنطقه عامه اما في لبنان فقد
اشاد رئيس حكومه تصنيف الاعمال نجد بهذا
الاتفاق ووصفه بفرصه للتنفس في المنطقه
والتطلع الى المستقبل
نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من بيروت حسن
فحص الكاتب الصحفي ومن اربيل الدكتور مهند
الجنابي النشره الحقوقي واستاذه العلوم
السياسيه اهلا بكم ضيوف الكرام اسمحوا لي
ان ابدا من بيروت معك استاذ حسن في الواقع
اتت التصريحات من لبنان متفائله
رئيس حكومه تصريف الاعمال نجيب ميقات يقول
بان هذه الاتفاقيه ستكون متنفس وستطلق
مسارا للمستقبل مسار ايجابي الى اي مدى
قادر ذلك ان يتحقق
تحياتي ستريم اهلا المشاهدين الكرام
وللضيف الكريم
اعتقد ان الجرعه التفاؤل اللبنانيه
سريعه كثيرا او متفائله كثيرا
بانعكاسات ايجابيه لهذا الاتفاق بالمدى
القصير جدا
اعتقد انه الاتفاق
مازال امامه فتره زمنيه قد تطول قليلا
يعني تتجاوز الشهرين الى ثلاثه اشهر
لليانعكس على الساحه اللبنانيه في البدايه
لان هناك ملفات اخرى تتقدم على الجدول
الاهتمامات لكلا البلدين
المتفقين يعني تبدا باليمن وثم العراق
والوضع السوري ولاحقا ان الوضع اللبناني
وهناك مقدمات لبنانيه ضروريه للوصول الى
هذه او تحقيق هذه الجرعه من التفاؤل التي
بدت لدى كل في اللبنانيه وليس فقط رئيس
الحكومه المؤقته او التصريف الاعمال لذلك
هناك خطوات
من المفترض ان تبدا يبدا العمل بها
والتشاور حولها فيما يتعلق بانتخابات
رئاسه الجمهوريه والاتفاق على شخص الرئيس
هل هو رئيس ممثلا لطرف معين يفرد فرضا او
رئيس توافقي يقود مرحله انتقاليه او اداره
ازمه
بالاضافه الى قدره هذا الرئيس على طرح
المسائل العالقه في الوضع اللبناني بين
الافرقه اللبنانيه وخاصه ما يتعلق
[موسيقى]
بالاستراتيجيه الدفاعيه التي تدور حول
مستقبل سلاح حزب الله في في المنطقه وداخل
لبنان ايضا واضافه الى قدره هذا الرئيس
على جمع الافقه اللبنانيين على الجلوس على
طاوله حوار
تؤسس لمرحله جديده
تفكفك الازمات التي ظهرت في السنوات
الاخيره في العقدين الاخيرين في العمليه
السياسيه وتشكيل الدوله
والحصص او او مساهمات كل مكون من المكونات
هل يرضى بهذا الحجم من التمثيل داخل
النظام وداخل المؤسسات الدوله كلها اسئله
مطروحه تسبق ايضا الوصول الى
نتائج نهائيه لهذا الاتفاق بترجم من هذا
الاتفاق يعني يجب التروي والحذر كذلك لانه
داخل البيت اللبناني هناك ترتيبات هناك
متغيرات قادره ان تؤثر كذلك على هذا
المسار دكتور مهند ماذا عن العراق خاصه
وان حضرتك تعرف بان ايران ارتبطت بملفات
وبمصالح معقده ومركبه في المنطقه العربيه
في مختلف الدول
والعراق من بين هذه الدول هل تعتقد بان
هناك
مسار ايجابي قادر ان يبدا العمل عليه في
داخل العراقي متعلق بهذا التقارب الايراني
السعودي
مساء الخير استاذه ريم تحياتي الكريم
استاذ حسن والسادة المشاهدين بكل تاكيد
على الرغم انه ايران تعمل على ساحه
اقليميه واحده ممتده من طهران حتى بيروت
ومروره من بغداد ودمشق لكن اعتقد ان هنالك
كل حاله يعني تختلف عندما نتعاطى مع هذا
الاتفاق ما بين الرياض وطهران انا اعتقد
في الحاله العراقيه ايضا من المبكر جدا
اعطاء الثقه للسلوك الايراني او محاوله
رفع يدها عن الميليشيات والفصائل المواليه
لها في العراق الحاله العراقيه نعتقد بان
حاله التهديدات اذا نلاحظ استاذي من الشهر
العاشر حتى الان مع مدح الحكومه الثقه
حكومه السيد السوداني الخطاب السياسي وحتى
على المستوى العمليات بالنسبه لنشاطات
الفصائل المسلحه قد انخفض بشكل كبير
باعتبار انه هذه الحكومه هي انبثقت من قوى
الاطار التنسيقي المقربه من ايران
والحليفه لايران وبالتالي التهدئه التي
تعتبر العراق المرتكز الامامي والمنطلق
لسياسات الاقليميه للتهرب من العقوبات
ايضا لنفوذها الاقليمي بالتالي انا اعتقد
بانه الحاله العراقيه قد تشهد مزيدا من
التعقيدات وستبقى ايران تحافظ على مصالحها
في العراق واضعاف الدوله ومؤسسات الدوله
العراقيه وهنالك الكثير من المؤشرات على
ذلك حتى المؤشرات الحديثه تشير الى هذه
النقطه على الحذر تتفقون على التشكيك على
الاقل في النوايا الايرانيه اسمحوا لي ان
ادافع بما انه ليس هناك طرف حاضر يدافع
على وجهه النظر الايرانيه ان ادافع انا عن
وجهه النظر الايرانيه استاذ حسن ايران
دخلت هذا المشروع ابرمت اتفاقيه جد مهمه
وتعلم حضرتك بان ايران ليست فقط نظام
ايران مشروع كانت تعمل عليه في المنطقه
عبر مختلف هذه الدول طيب ما الذي يسطرني
الى دخول مثل هكذا اتفاقيه ان لم اكن
انوي ان اطبقها او ان انفذها وان لم تكن
لينيه على الاقل حسنه في محاوله ايجاد
حلول المنطقه
دعيني اولا
يعني واقول انه انا موافق نسبيا مع مقاله
الدكتور مهند ولكن
يسمح لي بان يختلف معه في جزئيه بسيطه
تستكمل المشهد ولا تعارضه ايران
ذهبت الى هذا الاتفاق
نتيجه حاجه ماسه لها داخليه واقليميه
ودوليه يعني انها تريد ان تفكك
حلقات العزله والازمات التي تحيط بها
وبدات تضغط بشكل اساسي على
مستقبل النظام اذا جاز التعبير من هنا
الايراني امام تساؤل وامام تحدي واضح بما
يتعلق بالساحه العراقيه هل هو يريد ان
يعزز دور الدوله وبناء الدوله في العراق
على حساب ميليشيات ام هو يفضل
بابقاء العراق في دائره اللا توازن في
صراعات الداخليه بين بين الفصائل المواليه
له
واطلاق يدها في التحكم بمصير الدوله ومصير
ومستقبل العراق
هناك مؤشرات جديه بان ان الايراني يريد ان
يصل الى تفكيك هذه الازمات
والاستثمار او ترجمه
وتسهيل الاستثمارات التي قام بها على مدى
عقود في المنطقه وان يذهب الى النتائج
النهائيه التي يريدها سواء في
انهاء حاله التوتر والعداء
مع دول المحيط العربي وخصوصا من الدول
الخليجيه وفي مقدمه من المملكه العربيه
السعوديه وايضا يريد ان يحصل على اعتراف
دولي بهذا الدوري الاقليمي وهذا الاعتراف
الدولي لن ياتي ولن ما لم يبدا الايراني
بتعاون جدي في حللت هذه الازمات وهذه
الساحات لذلك اعتقد ان
ما سيشهده العراق في في المرحله القادمه
هو
نوع من التميز بين الموقف الايراني وهو
موقف الفصائل يعني ستكون الحكومه
الايرانيه الى جانب الحكومه العراقيه على
حساب الفصائل والفصائل ستسعى بعيدا عن
ايران للدفاع عن مصالحها في وجه
اي محاوله من الحكومه او الدوله لتعزيز
دورها وسيادتها والامساك بالقرار السياسي
والاقتصادي والمالي وكل والامن والعسكر
فلذلك سنشهد مرحله تمايز بين الموقف اذا
كانت ايران وشرط وهذا التمييز شرط ان اذا
كانت ايران تريد ان تسمح ببناء دوله في
العراق وام لا تريد بناء هذه الدوله او لا
تسمح بها او ترى ان بناء الدوله في العراق
سيكون على حساب مصالحها
الاستراتيجيه في الاقليم فستعمل الى تقديم
الدعم او لمواقف الفصائل والاغضاء عن عما
يقومون به
ليس بالضروره بالعلن ولكن بالسر او من خلف
من خلف الكواليس
للحفاظ على مشروعها في عدم اقامه الدوله
اذا كانت
الدكتور مهند الدكتور مهند انك
تعرف الواقع يقول يعني هناك شكوك هل ايران
تود فعلا
توطيد علاقتها مع الدوله العراقيه
وان ترى دوله عراقيه مكتمله الاجزاء
ومكتمله المقومات خاليه من الحضور
الميليشاوى دخلها ما رايك
يعني استاذ حسن هو رسم صوره واقعيه جدا
الحاله العراقيه لكن يعني اضافه الى ما
تفضل به هي انا اعتقد بانه حاله التمايز
التي تحدث عنها انه ايران الان هي المهتمه
بابراز هذا التمايز او حاله اظهار سلوك
الفصائل المسلحه العراقيه على انه شانا
عراقيا وليس يتبع توجيهات ايرانيه او
سياسه ايران الاقليميه لنا في عام 2020
عندما حصل تصعيد كبير جدا في بغداد وفي
اربيل وفي عين الاسد من خلال نشاط الفصائل
المسلحه نتذكر ما قاله زعيم عصابه للحق
قيس الخزعلي بانه الحاله الايرانيه هي
يعني ليس بالضروره تؤثر على الحاله
العراقيه انذاك ايران جنحت الى هدنه نسبيه
مع الولايات المتحده ومع الحكومه العراقيه
السابقه لكن استمرار الفصائل المسلحه
بحاله التصعيد اظهروا هذه الحاله على انها
شانا عراقيا تحت عنوان المقاومه بالتالي
انا اعتقد بانه ايران مستفيده من هذا
التمايز هي لا تريد ان تذهب باتجاه تقويه
الدوله لا تريد ان تذهب باتجاه تعزيز
قدرات الجيش العراقي يوم امس او الاول من
امس كان هنالك
احتكاكثر بشكل كبير على الواقع في تكريت
بين اكبر قوه مهمه في العراق وهي جاهز
مكافحه الارهاب مع فصيل من يشاء ينتمي الى
كتاب حزب الله المدعومه من ايران حاله
التوازي وحاله التوافق مع الدوله العراقيه
هي مرحله انيه ولا يمكن وصفها او اعتبارها
مرحله استراتيجيه وثابته في السياسه
الايرانيه تجاه العراق لانه ببساطه نقول
انه الحكومه الحاليه قد تشكلت من حلفاء
ايران وبالتالي ايران مجبره ومضطره على
دعم جهود الحكومه وتخفيف حده الضغط الذي
تمثله الفصائل المسلحه لكن اذا قارنا هذا
النشاط مع الحكومه السابقه حكومه السيد
الكاظمي نلاحظ بانه ايران كانت منغمسه
بشكل فاعل في دعم الميليشيات والفصائل وقد
تتغير هذه الحاله عندما تاتي الانتخابات
القائمه هذه القوى السياسيه المرتبطه
بايران هي قلقه جدا من واقعها السياسي
واستمرارها السياسي ولهذا السبب هي ذاهبه
باتجاه تغيير قانون الانتخابات ونظام
الانتخابات واعتماد النظام القديم الذي
يضمن بقائها لو كانت هذه القوى السياسيه
واثقه وايران جاده في دعم جهود الدوله
العراقيه لتركت الساحه الى الديمقراطيه
الحقيقيه لكن اعتقد بانه لو جاءت انتخابات
وجاءت قوه او حكومه الغير مرتبطه بايران
او لا تدور في فلك ايران انا اعتقد بانه
التوقيف الجزئي او التجميد الجزئي لنشاط
الفصائل سيتم استئنافه بشكل كبير كما حصل
خلال عامين ونصف من حكومه السيد الكاظم
معك بالملف السوري ان سمحت لي وسوريا ارض
تشتبك فيها المصالح الدوليه روسيا
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه شيء من لبنان
نتحدث عن حزب الله وايران هل تعتقد بان
الملف السوري قد يكون اعقد خاصه وان ايران
لا تستثمر فيه فقط اسلحه وانما كذلك
تستثمر فيه اموال وقد ينهكها هذا او انهك
ها عبر السنوات السابقه
لا شك ان الايراني يسعى الى
تثبيت مكاسبه على الساحه السوريه والمرحله
القادمه والمقبله ستكون ستشهد نوع مختلف
من الطاعات الايراني مع هذه الساحه خاصه
في ظل حاله الانفتاح العربي على سوريا
والجهود التي تبذل لحل الازمه المتبقيه في
محافظه ادلب مع الجانب التركي برعايه
روسيه لذلك يا ايران ستعيد
ستعيد انتشارها اذا صح التعبير السياسي
والامن والعسكري على الساحه السوريه مع مع
محاوله الابقاء على هذا الوجود
بما لا يتعارض مع
تعزيز
موقف الدوله السوريه ولكن ليس لن يكون على
حساب وجودها لانها تستخدم هذه الساحه كم
الساحه اللبنانيه
لتثبيت المعادله الاقليميه
وحصتها في تقاسم في تقاسم المنطقه مع
القوى الاخوه الاخرى لذلك
ستشهد المرحله القادمه نوعا جديدا من
واسومه جديده من التعاطي الايراني مع ساحه
السوريه ولكن لن يكون ولن يؤدي الى
الانسحاب من هذه الساحه
لطالما كذلك حتى استعملت الملف السوري في
علاقه مع المفاوضات مفاوضات الملف النووي
كذلك والمفاوضات لا تاريخ محدد لبدايتها
ان كانت هناك مفاوضات اصلا اود شكركم جزيل
الشكر على المشاركه وكل ما تفضلتم به من
بيروت حسن فحص الكاتبه الصحفي ومن اربيل
الدكتور مهند الجنابي النشط الحقوقي
واستاذ العلوم السياسيه شكرا لكما